My name is Laila White.
It's my artistic name.
I'm a dancer.
Photographer and visual artist.
I'm a brunette, with curly hair
and a ponytail.
I'm wearing a floral print blouse,
blue jeans and behind me
there are some orange crutches.
I'm sitting in front of the painting
of Theodoros Stamos
and throughout this interview
some images of me
are going to be shown.
I started dancing in the dark
when I was young.
I didn't know I was going to be
a dancer or a photographer.
I was bullied a lot in high school
and when I got home,
I would lock myself in my room,
I would turn off the lights
and put on some music.
And...
I wanted to feel the sensation
that my body felt to express
the pain, the rage...
And then I link it a little bit
with photography.
But I never, at any time,
put it in my mind
that I wanted to be a dancer,
because I thought...
"with a disability I can't be a dancer"
because at that time
I didn't know anybody.
Years later a person gave me
the opportunity to be able to move.
That's when I started training myself,
dancing with collectives
and going to workshops.
I also started to mix it with
photography,
because for me photography
has something very special
that I don't usually show to everybody.
I started with photography,
because I have a twin sister,
from whom I've been separated
since I was very young...
I was trying to find the other face
that I couldn't see for all these years.
The photography is a reflection
of my twin sister.
I'm interested in the general movement,
in the movement of the body,
in the expression of the body.
I started to study a little bit
how people walked and if these legs
could also say something
about the way they walked,
the position that the feet took.
So that's when I got curious.
If I could take that movement
to the stage, what would happen?
Each body has a way of explaining
and expressing itself,
without using words,
simply through movement
we are able to express a lot of things.
My interest is in this movement
and in the image in a scene.
During the COVID pandemic,
I started to create a piece
and that's when I started to create
about some ideas that I have,
which is about a dream that I had
and that I still have often,
which is...
going out without crutches.
So the idea has been around
for a long time.
And I had the opportunity
to bring it into a space
and how I can translate the dream
into a performance space.
And I started to work
on the weight of the dream,
because it felt so agonising,
so much anguish...
because I felt very anguished
for not having my crutches.
And over the years I understood
that maybe this dream
that my twin sister...
is giving me the opportunity to feel
a sensation that I could never feel.
I feel very fortunate...
to have chosen what is
meant for me.
But then I also think
what about my twin sister?
If she had the chance
to live through this...
would I...
Exchange for a moment
our experience...
that each one of us could have
the opportunity to live for ourselves.
It's hard to explain.
There are things that can't be explained
and have no reason why.
When you realise that you've had
two very different and complicated lives
at the same time,
you can't question what's easy
or what you can choose.
If I was chosen at the time,
when I came to Spain,
it was for a reason.
I always think that I was chosen
for something.
I don't know what I'm going to do,
but I'm here to do something.